[Musik]
ein
er bricht
[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israel
heute gibt's eine richtig leckere
erdbeertorte mit einem cookie boden das
heißt ich habe einen leckeren cookie mit
einer sahne creme bestrichen und da
tolle erdbeeren draufgelegt der kuchen
geht wirklich super schnelle sehr
einfach das heißt wohl durch einfach
etwa und frisch vom hof und dann
bereitet diese torte sowie täglich
superschnell superlecker versuche
einfach und ganz viel gemacht ich zeige
jetzt erst einmal die zutaten für den
teig für den cookie teig brauche ich 250
g weiche butter 100 vom braunen zucker
200 gramm weizen zucker etwas vanille
fragt eine 213 mal war mayer 302 therese
backpulver 100 milliliter lauwarme milch
und 150 vom bug fester show getroffen
nämlich zuerst einmal die weiche butter
die kommt hier in die rührschüssel ihr
könnt den cookie teig auch gerne mit
einem handgerät zu bereiten
ich mache immer gerne in der
küchenmaschine weil ich dann beide hände
frei haben
jetzt kommt noch dass der braune zucker
mit rein dann etwas familie extrakte
vortages leben am limes morath frau weil
es kommt mit seinem und von elektra
werde ich gleich noch zeigen als ich
zeige euch gleich wie man hier die reste
auch bekommt aber zuerst einmal lasse
ich jetzt die bottroper mischung etwa 45
minuten kriegen verrühren
die butter masse geschmeidig sind die
eier kommen an ein anderes boot also
jedes einrühren und dann kommt das
nächste tor
die
werden sie jetzt noch verrückt werden
kann ich euch schon mal zeigen wie ihre
kanäle extrakt aus diese kleidung desto
noch raus zu kommen dann immer ein
bisschen milz und lebte hier rein dann
die flasche und so bekommt ihr wirklich
alle reste aus
auffällig im café jetzt kann ich hier
backpulver vermischen und geht jetzt nur
noch die zutaten hier rein
das heißt die bagger familie mischung
die vanille - und jetzt wird alles bei
niedriger stufe verrührt und es kommt
nur noch so viel milch das foto das ein
geschmeidiger teig entsteht
[Musik]
jetzt sei nur kurz die schoko stücke
eingerührt den teig völlig in meine
vorbereiteten bergring den habe ich
bereits 24 cm eingestellt
[Musik]
der teilweise zum bisschen weicher als
ein normaler cookie teig einem normalen
cookie teig habe ich nur zwei eier und
auch keine milch mit dabei denn der teig
ist oder nicht verlaufen sondern so
unschöne kekse entstehen die ausstellung
und innen weich sind
bei dieser tat habe ich mich jetzt dazu
entschlossen den titans in geschmeidiger
zu machen weil es eben doch torten
ähnlicher sein soll
[Musik]
den ford heißen backofen bei 170 grad
ober unterhitze für etwa 35 bis 40
minuten im innern darf der kunde gerne
noch ein bisschen feucht sein
jetzt ist der krieg boden abgekühlt und
ich kann jetzt auf eine form herauslösen
und beim abkühlen dafür die mittel so
ein bisschen zusammen aber das ist auch
so gewollt denn dann habe ich ganz viel
platz für ganz viel sahne
[Musik]
mit einem trockenen rapper kann man ganz
gut lösen
jetzt setze ich ihn auch direkt auf eine
tortenplatte und stängeln einfach kurz
zur seite
in der zwischenzeit zeige ich euch schon
mal die zutaten für die creme für die
creme brauch ich 400 gramm schlagbare
250 gramm magerquark bieten teelöffel
seiner partei noch butter zucker endlos
von extrakt dann zum dekorieren etwas
erdbeermarmelade ohne stückchen und fein
passiert etwa 50 redakteure und ein
kleines stück kokosfett und hier habe
ich noch etwas 500 gramm erdbeeren die
ad lahn befreite zum grün und bässe
basieren oder wie je nach größe auch
vierte
[Musik]
wir fangen könne trip zur seite und
jetzt werde ich die sahne creme zu
bereiten dafür nehme ich jetzt die sahne
und gebt ihr vier teelöffel an abbas mit
reinen während im rühren und beste es
noch steif schlagen
[Musik]
damit steigt natürlich ganz kurz zur
seite
jetzt ist an der reihe den gebe ich
jetzt in etwas grösseren flüsse so dass
sich die sahne gleich noch unter heben
kann
da kommt das restliche sonderfahrt mit
dazu
dann natürlich vanille extrakt vanilla
zum ersten vertragen sich ganz ganz
wunderbar und ein esslöffel butter
zucker ihr könnt ihn auch komplett
weglassen denn der coup ist schon
wichtig und die eltern sind ja auch
richtig sitzt wegen möchte ich die sahne
creme es nicht versucht haben mit
einrühren
[Musik]
und die sahne unterheben
do
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die leckere quark sahne
creme in die mitte sondern richtig
einfache aber richtig lecker da droht
jedem arschbacken vom schmeckt immer gut
und sich immer gut aus und die wird
jetzt ein bisschen verteilt da ist gar
nicht schlimm wenn das nicht so perfekt
aussieht genau worüber nämlich aussehen
nicht perfekt
[Musik]
die erdbeeren offen da raus und zwar
einfach wirklich ganz so alles hinlegen
so dürfen richtig schöner als zwischen
der erdbeerzeit auf der torte
[Musik]
aber für mich ist noch schlimmer wenn
ich sicher auch die torte also ihr seht
sie euch nicht auch noch
[Musik]
bruno
politik schon richtig groß jetzt nehme
ich muss die marmelade die habe ich
gerade ein bisschen erwärmt die bringt
jetzt auch ein bisschen frische mit rein
und vor allem auch ein bisschen süße die
könnt ihr darüber geben müsst ihr aber
nicht drüber löffeln oder auch mit einem
pinsel auftragen wo wir das gerne möchte
ich mache mir hin und land bekommen die
erdbeeren einen schönen glanz
[Musik]
ich habe ich jetzt bereits die kuvertüre
temperiert das heißt ich hab sie über
dem warmen aber nicht kochenden
wasserbad erwärmt
zwei drittel davon dann habe ich so ein
wasserbad heruntergezogen und drittel
eingerührt und ein bisschen kokett ist
man dabei damit die schokolade schön
glänzt und die wird jetzt auch einfach
ganz wahllos und willkürlich darüber
geträufelt
[Musik]
u
und trocken werde ich noch mit einem
jetzt mache ich die zahlreiche kurz weg
sondern probieren jetzt kann ich die
torte anschneiden murat ist leider nicht
da daher muss ich mich leider opfern und
muss die torte probieren arbeit macht
das natürlich ganz gerne
das wird jetzt gleich passieren dass die
erdbeeren runterfallen aber das ist gar
nicht
ich hatte die toppits übrigens nachdem
schichten gar nicht meinen kühlschrank
aber ihr könnt natürlich nachdem
schichten und dekorieren nochmal in den
kühlschrank stellen da wir die sache
auch noch mal ein bisschen fester und
bleibt dann auch schön stand fest
aber ich muss ehrlich sagen die gewisse
hier sind so verlockend dass ich jetzt
gleich probieren muss
für den innen außen ist der zeigten sind
künftig müssen dann hier die etwas
trockenere schicht aber absolut nicht
trocken und ihnen die feuchte schlecker
ich würde gern noch mal probieren wenn
die kamera aus ist also ich kann nur
sagen die torte schmeckt super lecker
sehr erfrischend und vor allem fast
diese schokolade aus dem cookie teig
wirklich super dass du der feuchte
cookie die frischen erdbeeren und die
nicht zusammen passen wirklich
hervorragend zusammen
und falls ich euch jetzt auch ganz viel
lust auf diese trasse gemacht habt dann
passiert es auch hier auf meinem blog
vorbei auffälliges doch de
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß
danach machen und bis zum nächsten mal
schön hängt mir überall schokolade
erdbeer nun alles probiert vater kamera
aber das nehme ich es mit und ist den
kuchen ist einfach hinter der kamera
[Musik]